hi there steve kaufman here i have come
back from my ski holiday i was at big
white
uh for about six seven days with uh my
wife my son mark and his wife and
their three kids
uh fabulous uh first three four days
very sunny then we had some poor
visibility if you look up big white on
the internet you'll see that it's a
fabulous area they've had i think 12
centimeters of snow in the last eight
hours
great snow i took some pictures i'll be
throwing them up there
um but now i'm back we had to drive
through you have to drive basically over
two mountain passes
one is the okanagan connector which
connects uh kelowna with merit and then
over the cocoh and there's a huge
snowstorm there on the kokohala highway
right through the mountains
and i of course saw that on the internet
so i was able to sneak through there we
had a lot of snow yesterday
i was cross-country skiing in an area
called the telemark uh something other
cross country area out of cologne
because
my wife and i spent two nights in
kelowna with some very good friends
and so we had snow there
then we had a window this morning we
were able to get out four hours driving
over to mountain ranges to get back to
vancouver
i just want to have a bit of a rant here
a little bit tired we've been staying up
late and drinking wine with friends and
so forth and driving home and that
uh reading the newspaper and there was
this uh protester there's a sort of a
native protest going on in canada
uh
some of the protesters with their sign
has a bunch of gibberish on it saying
and then it had at the bottom just
saying
and there's this whenever i see this
just saying
like people will comment on my blog or
hear
and come out with whatever opinion they
have and then just say just saying
that it really annoys me really what
what is meant by just saying like if i
have an opinion
i present my opinion i'm not just saying
i'm expressing my opinion the person
listening can either agree or disagree
but this just saying implies like i
don't really want to have a discussion
on the subject
but what i am saying you know uh is
obviously right and irrefutable and i'm
just kind of tossing it out there
but i don't want you to in any way
dissect it or discuss it or contradict
me
because i don't want to have an argument
because i'm just saying
and and this kind of attitude i find is
quite common i don't know where it comes
from i don't remember seeing that 20 30
years ago but today it's very common
that you know let's have an argument uh
like i just think this and so there you
go just saying
um i'm not that way you know and i think
it's it's whatever we do we should do it
um in a spirit of like how about rather
than just saying don't say that say just
go for it again the friend that i stayed
with in kelowna has been pretending to
study
spanish for three years has never done
much
don't just dabble you know go for it if
you want to learn
and put the effort in and you'll learn
or just don't do it do something else
but don't sort of just saying or just
halfheartedly doing
uh
that's not my style but i guess
other people are different i'm enjoying
my korean i did a fair amount of
cross-country skiing up at big white and
that gave me an opportunity to listen to
korean it's still not as much fun to
listen to korean because the content is
still somewhat boring compared to what
i've been listening to in russian and
czech
but i'm making progress i have now gone
to wikipedia in korean and i'm reading
up on korean history
i'm sort of isolating more and more of
the basic patterns of korean and reading
them over and over again reviewing my
examples at link
uh and i've started speaking to a tutor
uh
little monu as she's known at link one
of our tutors and if she agrees perhaps
the next time i speak to her
i will record the discussion so you can
get a sense of just how poor my korean
is at this stage
bear in mind that i studied korean about
seven or eight years ago for about six
months on my own this is before we had a
link
and of course i'm helped very much by
the fact that
50 of the words
in korean are of chinese origin or even
a larger percentage
and the sentence the word order is very
similar to japanese so i think i have a
big advantage over
someone who doesn't have any experience
in asian languages so you'll be hearing
from me with regard to korean
um
other than that i'm trying to see if i
can line up some interesting discussions
david manseray has contacted me about a
possible discussion about independent
education and i mean there's no question
in my mind that we have to move in that
direction i
mentioned on my blog
that there was an article in the
canadian
press about that stated that the average
debt loan for a student
of student loans like people graduating
from university took 14 years to repay i
don't believe that anyway it's based on
their assumptions as to how much money a
person would make and how much they
would actually be able to save and repay
their loans but nevertheless
people get indebted to the tune of
twenty thirty forty fifty thousand
dollars i mean four years at university
costs a hundred thousand plus dollars if
you go to first class us
university it can be two hundred
thousand dollars what do you really get
for it
uh there was a
presentation put on by someone at this
ted series on how he did a four-year
course
uh at mit
in computer science and did it on his
own and achieved the same and spent one
percent of what it would have cost to go
to mit i'm also going to try to contact
him
and have a web conversation with him i'm
going to try to contact stephen krashen
and have a web conversation with him uh
and so we can have some conversations on
some of these subjects
but david wants to talk a bit about
david mansour he wants to talk a bit
about independent education or
and and it's really more a matter of how
the person being educated is in the
driver's seat and gets to choose where
to get the education and
rather than having it
something that's marketed at him by
these universities who are really
selling
basically four years at an institution
in order to get a diploma and you get
the diploma for having spent four years
at the university rather than for what
you necessarily learned or or can do
anyway we'll get into some of these
subjects
um
yeah basically that's about it
back here we're gonna have to work
through all my accumulated email and
other stuff
and i look forward to uh to having some
more exchanges with people
thank you for listening bye for now